[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tél
si d'être avec nous ce soir sur des
riffs et quel bonheur on est content
c'est le deuxième épisode
on va revenir sur tous les jeux à la
télévision
on va rire on espère vous allez voir des
candidats qu'ils se trompent
des animateurs qui titille des candidats
et vous allez voir également toutes les
clips en animateurs car ce soir pour la
première partie de cette émission ils
seront tous déguisés
à commencer par celle qui est à ma
droite ariel benhaim des chiffres et des
lettres applaudissements pour ariane
bayle haim est d'ailleurs venu lui qu
elle est venue avec bertrand renard
c'est quoi cette nouvelle
le compte est bon elle est venue alors
je n'ai pas compris
jean luc lemoine a priori vous êtes en
quoi l'eau romejko mais quel rapport il
apparaît là c'est jean luc lemoine jean
luc lemoine près laurent romejko pas
encore là là là je peux vous dire là
c'est fort il ya jean michel merle
haggard skate avec nous
il est papauté isabelle victoria
silvstedt
et ça ira très bien
il ya également jean-luc reichmann
carrière mais c'est long et c'est réussi
et enfin c'est l'un des maillons forts
de cette émission
enora boccolini balla gaye nous allons
pas correct correct vous êtes le maillon
faible au revoir et il ya avec nous ce
soir
le perte far away
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces données sur les routes on dirait pas
le père fois il fait peur on dirait la
meuf dans misery beaucoup sans rigoler
et nous mêmes angoisses mais dans quoi
sont mes deux fous quoi on dirait que
vous êtes morts depuis cinq six ans je
revis qu'est ce qui dit que si tu revis
question je revis d'accord quand tu
paies le père fouras et c'est un mec
bourré iglo allez vous allez voir ce qui
vous attend sautoir au regard des gens
leurs deux filles en délire avec sa
reprise de nuit de folie les mots puis
comme un libertaire a débuté dès hier
comme on dit dans le métier je [__]
sur un sumo et j'embrasse ceux sophia
loren sur le cul ouvrez la bouche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais qui sont pris pour des yaourts
c'est pas merkel dans cette paire que
vous allez être bien sûr des huit avec
nous ce soir il y aura des moments qu il
y aura des inédits et il y aura comme on
dit dans le métier il y aura deux trois
pépites
bien sûr il y aura camille combal et
bertrand chamerois qui arrivent sont
préparés également une chronique sur les
jeux télé et on sait que vous les aimez
pour le moment on va démarrer cette
émission avec ce qu'il ne fallait pas
louper dans les jeux télé c'est parti on
va faire ce qu'il fallait pas louper et
sachets autour de cette table je préfère
vous prévenir
il y en a un ou une qui peut trembler
car tout à l'heure nous testerons un jeu
qui fait un carton dans un autre pays et
peut-être qu'on a volé quelque chose qui
vous appartient et que vous allez
retrouver derrière cet écran tout à
l'heure et qui se fera peut être broyés
je ne peux pas vous en dire plus mais
faites les missions dans la sérénité et
un moment peut-être que tout va basculer
voilà je préfère vous le dire pour le
moment on va démarrer avec le roi des
jeux c'est bien sûr nagui convient de
voir dans les extraits c'est un petit
peu ma gi oh je sais gérard louvin la
production française ainsi les bêlements
même s'il ne connaît pas dave depuis 40
ans c'était dans n'oubliez pas les
paroles est ce que vous rappelez quand
omar et fred sont venus ils devaient
chanter quoi vous rappelle ce qui devait
chanter ou pas
si un moment ils sont pleines hélène
qu'il est fort bravo jean michel le
maire hélène de roch voisine
vous allez voir sa part complètement en
live regardez ça
[Musique]
ces tables décennales ou
je lève
trop [__]
et ouais
ma
quoi
ici
[Musique]
m
moi
[Musique]
on ne laisse pas tomber et d'ouverture
c'est une femme libérée tu sais ces
principes à 6
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
amélie cents us et ibiza
[Applaudissements]
nadine et omar et fred
alors que d'ouvrir la politique et lui
nagui en fait il a la chance d'avoir un
orchestre qui le suit dans tout ce qui
fait ce qui n'est pas notre cas
imaginez nous si on n'a ni d'eva
n'oubliez pas les paroles avec te fasses
ça veut dire ce serait n'oubliez pas la
musique en fait une catastrophe pour
vous quand vous la glisse est vraiment
le taulier du jeu ou paille isabelle
morini-bosc va préférer des animateurs
de jeux
c'est un des préférés la gaffe c'est
votre préférée n'ont jamais rien compris
à l'effet a pas compris qu'elle avait la
gare raconte effet si j'aime bien la
gaffe aux jaune et noir - nagui pour moi
c'est le meilleur parce que justement il
a apporté une espèce de modernité et du
second degré il charrie lui-même duval
les candidats et ça pour le coup ça
plutôt et c'est nouveau c'est mon
préféré en ce qui me concerne jean luc à
moscou la gaffe également jean-luc
lemoine qui étant laurent romejko je le
rappelle si vous nous rejoignez un bien
entendu vous posez la question à kia
laurent romejko jean luc lemoine l'a
d'abord j'ai posé la question à laurent
romejko le collègue
moi j'aime beaucoup laurent romejko
personne sinon moi j'aime bien julien
courbet non mais c'est vrai quand elle
est déjà très bon bien qu'on adore pour
le moment on va continuer sur nagui
c'est un de ceux qui titille le mieux
les candidats parce que dans tout le
monde veut prendre ma place c'est vrai
qu'à une grosse mécanique mais mine de
rien ça tient beaucoup sur nagui
regarder ça cinéma1 sylvain chez disney
dans quaden beau non c'est une blague à
lui parce que ce sont des mots écoutez
ce pas
j'ai pas pensé aux puces non non c'est
moi qui suis un délicat en y pensant
dans quoi dolbeau se prend t-il lépi
provoquant la chute de tous les
éléphants du cirque
donc wait denbo se prend les pieds 1
dans quoi pousser longtemps puisque je
fais le mentionnait un ballon d'un mot
se prend les pieds dans un ballon et
tous les éléphants tombe peut-être dambo
dans ses oreilles alain soreil nos bons
vieux vous dire je vous pas cela parce
que je l'aimais bien je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez chez vous réagissez sur
twitter mais nagui ont promis avec nagui
je vous ai toujours cru que cela bizarre
moi j'adore ce qu'il fait mais là pour
le coup le pauvre malheureux dans la lah
il peut le prendre mal le monsieur bah
ouais je peux vous dire c'est pas parce
qu'on a des grandes oreilles qu'on n'est
pas beau gosse c'est pas un problème
d'avoir des grandes oreilles soupçonne
d'avoir une tâche ou quoi on s'en fout
c'est moi vous sortez tout de suite du
rôle de sa vie
[Applaudissements]
on va enchaîner avec qui veut gagner des
millions a présenté par mon ancien
campus saint jean pierre foucault qui
embrasse fort je suis sûr qu'ils nous
regardent et ça a cartonné d'ailleurs
cette année l'église mais qui veut
gagner des millions
en prime ça très très bien repris 1
gérard c'est vrai ça très bien marché et
là on va voir le duo michael youn ary
abittan il était très très engagé au
profit de l'association ela jusqu'au
moment où ils ont besoin d'un joker vous
allez voir ça qui a déjà participé à qui
veut gagner mire oui vous convient vous
avez gagné deux fois et deux fois 72000
c'est bien normal c'est vachement bien
et vous les hélices cobham bien sûr mais
bien sûr ça mais j'ai adoré et alors
pour le coup même si on est habitué des
plateaux télé et nous fait flipper
franchement on vous l'avait fait ouais
j'avais gagné 72 mille pareil fort il
est quand même si tu regarde bien il
fait très attention à ce qu'il dit si si
c'est ici il est assez mal à cause de la
situation je parle hein mais il fait
tout pour quand même aidé les installer
on va regarder cet extrait avec arrêt
habitants et michaël youn regardé
c'était la première fois que ça arrivait
donc il veut gagner des millions
et toi instinctivement tu tu aurais dit
la crème à moissac six mois et moi je
pars d'ici à me faire rentrer chez eux
après chez moi on va prendre le joker du
a donné la vie de la vie des anges la
vie des gens
[Musique]
à
moi je veux grave certains des résultats
aussi moisie c'est à dire qu'en disant
deux en dix ans de qui veut gagner des
millions c'est jamais arrivé ça personne
ne veut nous aider
dans toute l'histoire de km et ça n'est
jamais rien voulu à plus de 102 vous
tournez les gémeaux pour cent cette
année mais qui sont pris pour des
yaourts
on est les chats noirs de l'émission
mais c'est la loi c'était la première
fois que ça arrive et c'est non il cinq
ans et bien oui beaucoup lüthi lui avec
l'ancêtre de pékin express c'est la
carte au trésor s'est opposé deux
candidats avec des hélicoptères des
courses contre la montre des énigmes
vous allez voir qu'après motuelle c'est
l'émission la plus dangereuse du parti
qu'on doit alors font des bonds tard au
passage de l'immensité des travaux qu'il
a fallu pour construire cette merveille
et géraud casser la figure j'ai raté mon
garage
on y va monsieur allez on va vous je
vous ai dit doucement au bordel c'est
bon allez vas-y roule mais doucement
doucement merde et trop monsieur
wolkowitsky qui doit être avec mon frère
est donc messieurs messieurs
or bien
[Musique]
mais ça
monsieur
on la reconnaît bien sûr le cousin des
lois
c'est bien on va montrer ses extrêmes
parce qu'ils étaient d'une violence avec
les gens qui les ait décru moi je me
suis un garçon de 10 ans avec m'excite
vous avez tenu à faire de votre journée
que de me conduire et le mec il était
terrifié l'a conduit effectivement moi
j'étais hyper je viens pas vous avez
c'est exprès oui mais devrait passer ce
jeu là il ya eu un truc dans pékin
express qui est très très drôle ces deux
français alors est il y en a un qui va
se faire couper les cheveux c'était en
corée et écoutez bien ce qui va lui dire
hey regardez la coiffure après vous
réagissez juste après allez c'est parti
bon par contre si mon prof comme le mec
qui vient de coiffer là on est mal
barrés de tapas les mêmes cheveux avant
d'accord ça va mais françois n'a pas de
quoi s'inquiéter il est entre les mains
d'un véritable professionnel qu il ya
neck oriane coiffure un moderne moderne
les cheveux très courts
non non mais ça va vite ça va être bien
ça très bien [__] mais qu'est ce que
c'est amanda quand c'est pas fini
non c'est bien franchement non
honnêtement le dégrader et à tomber à
temps c'est énorme c'est énorme
[Musique]
c'est absolument le mec il a massacré ya
pardon faire vous donnez moi c'était en
grèce où j'avais été chez le bart à un
vieux barbier et je me suis dit je vais
me faire ce délire là donc il fait ça
déjà tué il a un coût tchouta peur
quitter et étranglerait fera quitter
gorge en plus vous avez la barbe de samy
de scooby doo c'est-à-dire et la jeanne
d'arc de puceau et le mec ça se passait
très bien je commençais à respirer un
petit peu et d'un seul coup j'ai pas il
sait il a kiffé une amie une vieille
notion peu dans l'eau sur la tête je
ressentais plus arrière j'avais les
cheveux gras dans une catastrophe
mais bon ça va ça s'éclaircit dit quand
même ben je ressemblais de friteuse mais
sinon c'est alors la parler d'un jeu
beaucoup plus calme qui passe tous les
jours sur france 3 à l'envers dans les
jeux calmes et vous allez voir on va
bien rigoler aussi vous connaissez cela
m'a bien sûr le principe de slam
ce sont des mots croisés à la télévision
et je vous le dis à l'époque sur france
3 il m'avait proposé de 2,2 présent très
stable et c'est vrai que cyril féraud le
fait beaucoup mieux que moi et vous
voilà il m'avait demandé vous imaginez
moi dans ce tableau car n'est ce là un
carnage ça veut dire l'émission elle
aurait duré deux semaines à venir
les beaufs mêlée bot croisé thirteen
kata et regarder ça cartonne sur france3
regarder ça
combien de l'année pour comme tata
incroyable il avait eu de longues depuis
longtemps en panne on distingue que deux
dans l'empreinte digitale empreintes
digitales jean-pierre consonnes annonce
alors ça c'est l'émission d'attraits
c'est juste
qui a besoin de chaleur le gland le
gland qui a besoin de chaleur le glabre
bout d'un parlement finalement c'est pas
merkel regarde slam ya déjà merci
jackass moi j'ai participé à remplacer
vrai ouais ouais
et c'est super compliqué où il a fait
toutes les mères de la beauté il
s'appelle ben haim d'entamer moi
j'aurais adoré faire pyramide voit les
comment s'appelle d'être de sabatier la
mot de passe j'avais fait j'adore devons
emmener d'éléments vous appelez vous
inquiétez pas on va passer à une autre
émission vous devez bien aimé c'est des
chiffres et des lettres à près de 50 ans
ils ont vu défiler des centaines de
candidats il fallait pas rater c'est la
participation de jean michel maire à
cette émission à l'âge de 10 ans et oui
il a fait les chiffres des délais qui
nous avait caché ça regarde
coucou monsieur siméant 7 pas mieux
mature matures
la coutume ou d'un bateau mais il ya un
jeune garçon de blois c'est sa fille
annoncé satellifax bon oui j'ai fait
connaître avec masturber
m
mais ils n'ont presque pas avoir la tête
qui buvaient est-ce qu'on peut revoir la
tête fait une coupe à la coréenne
le mozart de la tob déjà jeune est déjà
très mature tiff et noir est ce que
quand tu sors quand on sort qu'elle
cache que vous pouvez juste faire
maintenant vous êtes le maillon faible
donc regarder des adhésifs a dû vous
êtes le maillon faible c'est toi tu ne
dis que je suis le maillon faible la
toile font pas passer on va passer à ce
qu'on a vu ou pas vu à la télé c'est
parti j'ai pas vu à la télé alors je
vous propose des séquences home edition
les a vus ou pas à l'athénée ces partis
j'espère que chez vous passer une bonne
soirée
ce que le plus boubakeur
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent ça c'est
que vous êtes sur des vite cette
empreinte très spécial
ça s'appelle touche pas à mes jeux télé
on revient sur tous les jeux télé et
dans un instant il y aura aussi des
happenings puisque les chroniqueurs vont
tester des jeux télé et je le redis il
ya une des personnes ici qui va avoir
une grosse frayeur et je rappelle
également qu'il ya perte femme inquiète
avec dubaï à la télé ou plus chez nous
pas dans des chiffres et des lettres
gagné la partie avec le mot déambulateur
non ça va ça va
c'est tellement prothèse bon je vais
vous dire la vérité j'en ai marre de
vous voir comme faire moi j'ai besoin de
retrouver ma vraie bande c'est parti
parce que je suis aussi un magicien
[Applaudissements]
et sans pas plus loin comme ça
allez on peut continuer maintenant
cheveux ou pas vu à la télé oui jean lui
c'était bien mais il m'a dit mais il ya
un petit souci quand même
ouais je vais vous dire pourquoi parce
que cette personne je la préfère comme
ça ça va vous ouais en fait il est
déguisé en père fouras les îles à la
voie d'un chien à l'époque on repart de
sava fond dans le vus pas vu à la télé
est ce qu'on a vu sophie davant vire
qu'elle était allergique à l'odeur des
testicules dans le jeu de thierry
ardisson
happy hour oui moi j'ai dit penser que
oui ou non sophie davant est allergique
à l'odeur des testicules en tout cas
qu'elle lui ni à vous moi je pense qu'on
n'a jamais respecté testicules nous et
qu'elle n'a jamais restera non peut-être
dépasse tvix palais des cellules
et bien sachez que c'est le contraire
regardez vous appuyez sur le buzzer
quand vous pensez avoir la bonne réponse
toutes les réponses évidemment parle de
vous rassurer vaut mieux une contrainte
elles doivent commencer par un thé avec
qui n'auriez-vous pas aimé vivre
l'histoire d'amour
[Rires]
quelle est l'odeur que vous avez bien lu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça a dû vous plaire un jean-michel non
mais je l'adoré déjà avant mais à la
pizzeria j'aimerais avoir une aventure
avec elle j'aurais aimé maintenant j'ai
abandonné ne rappelle jamais à l'aise
des messages jamais de me rappelle à bon
temps chaud associé passer à autre chose
donc apparemment ce n'est pas au
programme c'est pas en tout cas c'est
pas son programme et ballons roses bon
est-ce que est valérie bénaïm parce que
vous êtes déjà fait draguer vraiment
bien bien lourd par à l'animateur ben en
fait non non moi je me remettez vous en
question alors enora vérité toute la
vérité
franchement ouais tout ça parce que tu
as dit oui à un mois c'est vrai enfin
chérie tu me connais je sais bien
d'autres prénoms n'ont jamais
physiquement plus les animateurs télé
c'est pas non plus des grosses bombes
atomiques quoi c'est laura je ne suis
pas animateur télé je suis avant tout
vendeur de roses
je fais ça je vais ça qu'on n'est pas
des est-ce qu'on a déjà vu un candidat
tellement impressionné par les questions
qu'il en oublie son adresse bah oui ça
résout en rien les caméras oui
puis les candidats ils viennent ils ont
ils n'ont pas l'habitude des caméras
plus à regarder ils perdent un peu leurs
moyens regard des premières questions à
gérard gérard quel est votre adresse aux
[__] le lagesse la classe et en plus
j'avais enfin jeu j'y vais tous les
jours en plus j'ai de la famille là-bas
bon je vais me lancer je veux dire dans
les 16 17 avenue du jusque là place quel
dommage
gérard quel dommage de rater la première
épreuve
lacombe c'est au tour de jean luc de
maintenant de jouer jean lui
concentrez-vous bien quel est votre
couleur préférée camions et beige rech
jean lui je vais vous aider vous
emportez actuellement une autre qu'un
vrai nom jean luc oui oui oui il dispute
la couleur quelques mois c'était le roux
jean luc tu es tu accélères jamais
l'égaler d'aller au bout la recevant
vous montrer cet expert et sachez qu'on
exclue pour touche pas mais je tenais je
peux vous dire qu'il ya peut-être un
petit truc en préparation entre jamel et
moi voilà je vous le dis peut-être qu'on
fera niemi chaussures des huit peut-être
seulement c'est pas impossible s'est pas
produit et vous en ferez bien sûr tout
le monde en sera bon on aura pas de
beaucoup d'oseille mais tout le monde en
sera dans les coulisses de mots de passe
est ce qu'on a vu patrick savatier pété
un plomb car il avait oublié le mot de
passe de son ordi est ce qu'on a vu un
jeu télé ou le but consiste à détruire
la voiture d'un candidat s'il se trompe
de réponse depuis tout à l'heure je vous
parle de quelque chose
oh non ça regardez d'abord cet extrait
my eyes et je vous parle de quelque
chose depuis tout à l'heure je suis garé
deux membres c'est vous êtes tous garés
devant mais nord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
élection peut arriver en france
non c'est impossible alors je vais vous
dire ce soir bidzos crusher arrive en
france et il arrive chez nous dans
touche pas à mes jeux tv est ce que est
ce que quelqu'un reconnaît cette clé
j'espère que c'est parce que je pense à
toi est ce que vous pensez quoi
j'espère que c'est pas la clé de mon
scooter c'est une clé de scooter mais
j'espère c'est pas la mienne c'est la
clé votre scooter non alors là attention
maintenant est-ce que vous reconnaissez
ce véhicule à temps ah non ça va c'est
pas bien est ce qu'on peut voir la
plaque s'il vous plaît la plaque
d'immatriculation dit raymond scouts
aussi non mais ressemble au mien mais
c'est pas lui et non je vais vous dire
[__] mais c'est seul au scooter
seniors c'est le couvert dès lors à
godard ou pas
la plaque d'égout attention s'il vous
plaît allez arrêter ma part été le
montrer sur gallega juste c'est vous et
ça va non et non
c'est très simple et non à ces benhaim
qui va avoir votre destin on ne sait pas
mais c'est horrible pour moi c'est comme
ça juste regarder en plus c'est rien
c'est ce qui va attaquer votre twitter
c'est rien est ce qu'on peut appeler ça
un ami à regarder c'est un ami c'est
regarder alors jks que vous l'entendez
jkc une crèche d'antan jusqu'à votre
prénom c'est vous c'est chic c'est pas
moche comme les cuisines
tu parles tu vas y prends ta voix
d'homme quand tu pars
[Applaudissements]
oui car vous allez vous approchez à
chaque fois deux scooters d'enora dès
que valérie bénaïm répondra mal donc je
vous dirais d'avancé le destin de
scooters des lots
dans ses mains à tout de suite son
émission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
na filâtre avait tout dans touche pas
mais je reviens sur tous les jeux télé
et juste avant la pub on revenait sur un
format qui vient dé royaume uni et ça
s'appelle beat the crush heures donc à
chaque fois qu'on répond mal à une
question ou père voilà une partie 1 de
son scooter de sa voiture et nous avons
récupéré le scooter d'enora malagré qui
est un scooter qui aime la vie et enora
malagré elle va avoir son destin dans
les mains d'un terrible
valérie bénaïm m&c des questions faciles
c'est des questions sur le code de la
route vous avez votre cote de leur maman
elle est nulle et tout civil s'il vous
plaît j qu'est ce que vous entendez
[Rires]
jusqu'à le fait ailleurs pour l'instant
attention voici la première question
pour valérie bénaïm valérie imaginons
que gérard louvin doivent emprunter
l'autoroute pour se rendre à la maison
de retraite la plus proche
quelle vitesse minimale sur l'autoroute
doit-il respecter gérard louvin ya pas
deux
jamais tes plans mais la vitesse
minimale sur l'autoroute
oui
[Musique]
allez v 60 kilomètres/heure 60
kilomètres heure la vitesse minimale à
respecter c'est 80 km heure justin est
ce que vous pouvez avancer jk de 5
mètres merci
[Applaudissements]
merci jusqu'à là ça s'approche on
commence à voir le scooter c'est bien là
mais c'est bon c'est bon on commence à
le voir
attention deuxième question valérie
bénaïm c'est christophe carrière veut
faire son rebelle et traverser la route
hors des clous quel sera le montant de
l'amendé
s'il se fait chopper et verbaliser
comment éduquer et se faire choper ce
sera la première fois que ça lui arrive
mais je ne peux pas voir des noirs mais
on n'est pas si les tunisiens et combien
vite
et s'ils traversent entre comme une âme
en de mauvais stationnement 17 euros 17
euros sachez qu sachez que c'est juste
os 4 0 90e sur un gîte a avancé de 5
mètres jusqu'à bercy
[Applaudissements]
valérie mélanine sachets non mais je
vous le dis il reste trois questions non
mais c'est vrai que vous fassiez du deux
sur trois non mais faudrait une armée 3
sur 3 ça serait bien si je remercie
gitans vous kiffez un gsm et jk je vais
le démonter
attention valet
jean michel maire qui ne boit jamais a
été contrôlé positif à l'alcootest
américaine il avait 0,8 gramme par litre
de sang le bon cran de plus il
téléphonait à kevin à son ex originaire
du brésil
combien de points lui sont retirés de
son permis
je rappelle que l'alcool est dangereux
pour la santé et puis je voyais pas à
moi comme motivé je sais la même soit
avec on va quand vous conduisez
oui mais je bois pas bah oui mais 6,6
pour martin dans quatre des six points
c'est terminé vous avez deux de leurs
six points j'espère que vous avez bon
sachez sachez qu'il y avait un piège
sévit points
j'allais dire non pourquoi bi poin
puisqu'il ya six pour l'alcool à et
trois points pour le téléphone au volant
mais les attractions sont cumulables la
wii mais le maximum qu'on peut retirer
d'un coup s'il est besoin donc huit
points ouais mais chez les messieurs non
non non non non gk vous me levais le
scooter non on me levais la suite
mais le joli nom avait du mal à lever
seulement tranquille gentil gentil
gentil gic un gentil gentil jk gentil
non mais les ultimes questions valérie
blais voici la question lorsque françois
hollande ne conduit pas son scooter
c'est julie qui passe le prendre en
voiture
si françois ne porte pas sa ceinture et
que la police les arrête
quel sera le montant de l'amendé rien
ses sérieuses et de la république et
banane
attendez je réfléchis pas les 45 ou si
c'est votre réponse
c'est votre oreille
séoul a su me plaît c'est julie qui
parce que prendre le président de la
république s'est certes le président de
la république c'est aussi un citoyen non
mais attends
et c'est julie qui conduis je le
rappelle sachez que le montant de
l'amendé ses voiles ou gic a réparé
toeava non non non non le montant de la
bande sera de 135 euros non aidera à ce
que voulait dire quelque chose à votre
scooter tient au fait je suis désolé en
tout cas ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
valérie labbé a défendu à 500
[Rires]
non mais les fait pas chica chica comme
on dit dans le métier
ouvrez la bouche et laura doha et enora
ça va ça va c'est bon c'est bon j k
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
la jcat tu te calmes
tu bosses et scooters battant dexter et
rigolent et d'orages
c'est bon
attendez et laura
ça suffit mental enora et nora et nora
et de rachat truc à vous dire vous avez
reconnu votre plaque d'immatriculation
sachez que ce scooter on l'a trouvé à la
casse ont de l'arpa on a mis votre
plaque
et il n'avait pas de moteur
cette aide à scooter à la casse moteur
sans rien scooter est encore là voilà
bah oui tenez voilà voilà
tenez je tenais pour l envoi cv la ligue
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est fini la sueur et vous on
espère vraiment que ce jeu n'arrivera
jamais en vrai à la télévision française
donc c'était un faux scooter vous
inquiétez pas mais c'est bien cher mais
j k c'est un vrai malade on va parler
d'une autre émission c'est fort boyard
ou fort beau agneau ou fort boyard ou la
parodie fort boyaux qui avait été faite
par qui vous rappelez vous c'est parti
[Musique]
alors attention on joue donc à fort
boyard on fore boyau avec tout le monde
autour de la table je vous décris des
séquences vous me dites s'il s'agit de
fort boyard ou de fort boyard un
candidat effectué des preuves sous
marine voit la clé mais oublie de la
rapporter fort boyard ou fort boyard
aboya en bois nous c'était de la parodie
on a regardé bon il va falloir que tu
descends dedans ce souterrain va trouver
une salle inondé c'est dans cette salle
que se trouve la clé dans cet été alors
fait croire à ses looks on gagnera le
magot aux italiens l'écran je vois
d'ailleurs bien daniel l'impasse a
choisi la phase à chaud et il fut
beaucoup de dates des lâchers est ce que
tu vois la clé combien vont bien c'est
bon t'es le meilleur
facile à battre on était là oui mais la
crise n'est pas pour ça que tu retournes
alors
un candidat traverse un tunnel et avale
une mouche fort boyard ou flamboyant
c'est quoi c'est qui jean luc arnaud
gidoin non malades alors si je vous
décapent quadricolor bruno vandelli ce
que vous rappelez de bruyne avons des
preuves d'une star comme ça c'était le
cocan et grave obstacle chorégraphe
c'est ce qui avait sauvé programme à
l'époque d'ailleurs avoué celui qui a
des sauts club alençonnais est pas là il
sauve le programme aussi la donne oui on
est avec toi on est la 190e jodie elodie
commence à additionner
[Musique]
allez vas-y bruno renaud vas-y qu'il y
arrive
[Musique]
j'ai une boule dans la gorge
[Applaudissements]
la bête la cnsa qui tombe sans cela ils
croient pas qu'il est enfant by crois
qu'il est dans la tartine avec batman
serge est pas un drame filmé avec le
chuck norris et jean luc ça c'était un
grand grand grand moment de fort boyard
non mais ça c'est un des millions qui a
fait fort boyard bonjour vous avez
ramené des clés ou pas ouais je n'avais
renée 400 kw non c'est vrai je crois qu
aux deux éditions
vous avez fait quoi quand vous avez un
truc le manche fille là où il y avait
des mygales autour de moi j'ai fait des
choses comme ça j'ai pas fais des trucs
très physique
c'est un jeu au pied droit enora je suis
invité je vais le faire non c'est vrai
ce que j'ai sur mon dessin tu le ferais
un bon jeu si j'ai pas le choix mais ça
va être l'enfer donc j'ai accepté ouest
très envie de le faire moi je moi je les
fais deux fois vous allez j'ai refusé
parce que je suis parti sans clé c'est
vrai c'est honteux la vérité et je sais
qu'il arrivera mais là je l'adoré comme
la dernière partie son clip il est
reparti avec la clé des minarets en
suisse
mais j'avoue que je ne pensais pas du
tout je pensais pas du tout c'était
aussi physique et moi je suis arrivé la
fleur au fusil j'avais fait la fête
toute la nuit je suis arrivé à la
rochelle
j'ai commencer et dès la première
épreuve lui ont séché sur qu'il a fallu
recommencer deux fois face partout à un
moment il m'a dit à la fin du jeu et m'a
dit c'était la première personne qui dit
courir moins vite non ben oui j'aimerais
de suivre nos résultats elle suivre ap
ne riez pas durer comme ça il n'y avait
pas
tu laisses iv va les faire vous savez
c'est pas fort boyard m au brésil mon
brushing des morts j'ai trop peur moi
des mygales des serpents tout ça je
serais un boulet où vous aviez fait pipi
ou du fouet exactement ouais mais je
vous dis à chaque fois à chaque fois que
j'ai plus fort boyard danger lécher les
essais de la bullshit
c'est mes deux plus beaux souvenirs de
vannes à un beau gosse qui fais pas le
malin devant des araignées et autres
scorpions fort boyard ou fort boyard
c'est baptiste giabiconi le playboy
après et vous allez voir il avec des
araignées scorpions et on ne le
reconnaît pas baptiste 3e c'est parti
ce contenu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bâtie s'il faut se fier
[Musique]
étais tu n'as plus rien sur toi tu n'es
plus rien sur quoi vous dire et c'est
pas patauge qui serait comme ça qu'est
ce qui ferait pas tâche dans un cas
connaît c'est un héros vous plaisantez
guerrier je vous jure un jour je vais
piégé patoche on va faire une rigolade
va lui montrer des images ici on va
mettre patoche avec des sapins avec ma
balance un héros c'est un guerrier mais
bon quand il à la maison quand il est
fait des crêtes quoi est ce qu'on a vu
une candidate qui se fait insulter par
ses coéquipiers parce qu'elle ne va pas
assez vite dans le labyrinthe fort
boyard
oui en prenant le volant à moyeu boyau
la parodier nouveau victoire du oui non
c'est dans la parodie
si la tension tout physique aujourd'hui
monsieur plus tôt pour nous engager de
progresser dans un labyrinthe et surtout
éviter de marcher sur les mygales et
grosse araignée célébrer oui bien sûr
[Musique]
allez vas-y verbe aller non messieurs
jeu il fallait pas y aller j'ai fais toi
appel qu'elle doit lire la liste est
inscrit sur l'une des milliards dans
l'île sur un truc de d'une [__] de ces
araignées de mer en temps mais tenable
mais arrêtez d'insulter encourager la
[__] on est avec toi
vasile n'ai pas peur pendant ces moments
là on voit je vous laisse vous allez en
bas âge ont ras-le-bol
je supplie n'en attendait pas tant
il n'y a pas la musique au musée est ce
qu'on a vu une candidate complètement
flippé dans une cabine téléphonique avec
un double
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
candidat mais il avait fait il était
cette fois ci c'est qu'ils avaient tissé
nominaux laëtitia milot qui a trouvé un
joli bluetooth et jean-luc non c'est
toujours jean luc c'est toujours
aujourd'hui regarde à l'eau voici les
nids elles font zik zak et des champions
et permettent la communique un petit
chat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ouvrirai chanter
dérobée
sans jamais être volés on peut les crb à
votre nez qui sont-elles pétrifiée et
oui quelle horreur
la pauvreté servillo lalalalalala sa
brochure ne fait pas tort les insectes
c'est parce que je préfère mais je
supporte c'est ça vous supportez vous
jean-michel aussi ce que ce problème
c'est que quand on sort de cette épreuve
là je les fais malheureusement on en
garde après pour une demi heure dont on
découvre tout le temps pendant une
demi-heure après un an crise toujours
dans lequel sont partout sur le nouvel
or ici on n'a pas d'insectes mon affaire
une autre épreuve
je vais demander à une personne que
j'aime beaucoup à cette table qui va
devoir retrouver des génériques télé de
venir avec moi c'est valérie bénaïm
monaco
berthod fa va vous envoyer des titres si
vous retrouvez les titres tout se
passera bien
valérie vous allez rentrer dans cette
cabine à les italiennes allez-y rentrer
dans cette même année m'a valu ne savent
à ces gens qui n'arrivent pas les fiers
qu'ils soient gentils mais après je
dirais la tête si mon père est ce qu'on
peut demander à monsieur de mieux le
plat c'est parce qu'il a la tête dure
elle est la peur voilà si tout ça merci
merci yahvé ce que vous appelez je peux
pas merci m'a dit que vous êtes un
amoureux c'est juste ou avant si on peut
lui enlever la tête parce que là ils en
accueillent la thaïlande
l'avis de la commission d'audition de
bundles s'il vous plaît l'aï les wikis
venir voilà mr ben voila voila valérie
voilà on fait année
ghoga
allez allez allez i maschi réalisme en
valais j'aime vraiment tu sais pas ce
que tu me connais tu es vraiment mais
c'est pas moi qui ai choisi maintien
mais à l'ériger rien à voir mais bien au
non vrai ça va il te donne pas en
spectacle devant toute la semaine on
arrête arrête armées je tremblais la
danse c'est rien ça a été tout net c'est
des grenouilles et des serpents arrête
arrête toi si là il bouge trop la vraie
vie à l'avant wild
regardez temps sur la honte d'avoir
servi en physio et en fait à manger pas
y aller
un peu trop s'il adore mais non ils
bougent trop il est très sympa c'est pas
tes pas créer un bisou cyril il me
regarde mal
opéra mais celui-là il vous préfèrent
alors est ce que vous voulez qu'on
entend dans les vins wayne is it on veut
enlever celui qui fait peur à l'est s'il
vous plaît manic aux délits météo sur le
dos de jean michel maire je trouve voilà
voilà parce que jean-michel adore les
ces reports voilà merci maman merci m'a
dit vous êtes un mois merci à dos comme
ça en étant de lui faire du bien on est
en toi m'a dit qu'il est comme ça allez
on y va
merci mme annick voilà voilà valérie
mais là c'est à vous maintenant
allez-y valérie je voulais entrer en
application
allez-y la légine roll à la
allez la salariée habitude à l'aise il a
rien dit je vais aller la pousser là
parce que on est en train de perdre la
personne allez on y va
alors oui mais rien d'anormal et les
ateliers décrocher le téléphone et wafa
pas vous envoyer des titres de
génériques télé décrocher votre
téléphone est d'aller les ententes dans
le téléphone dès que vous trouvez tout
se passe bien on continue et vous pouvez
rester et vous en aurez 10 à trouver dès
que vous aurez trouvé les 10 vous
pourrez sortir de la cabine
d'accord valérie ouais ok tu à gaz
nazies arrête on va aller vite décrocher
le téléphone vous allez continuer sinon
quoi mais décrocher c'est de là que vous
allez entendre les titres s'y coller
alors c'est paco les il s'est collé pour
balayer vous décrochiez alesi oui mais
quoi alors ces bons envoyés
c'est quoi c'est toi tu vois tu sais bon
moi tue c'est bon c'est bon ça fait un
clip retrouver sa marion aller valérie
voici le deuxième titre
[Applaudissements]
mes amours en savoie et la loire les
amoureux éconduit ça fait deux petites
attentions faudra trouver ni série voici
le troisième
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez la route à fond bon après on ne
trouvait pas aller troisième titre à
halle et valérie valérie ballet lit s'il
vous plaît donnez moi ça m'a s'est passé
s'est passé c'est des criques et ça
s'est passé
attention valérie valérie écoutez bien
voici
voici le prochain extrait vous en avez
trouvé 2 pour l'instant à léry aller
valérie leulliot prochain extrait
écouter et non non non aussi si c'est
juste prix soba non non non à l'étrier
allez ne vous inquiétez pas non mais
alors c'est quoi
[Musique]
d'abord
[Applaudissements]
le gardien citadins pour balenciaga m
bienvenue à toi et toi c'est fini c'est
fini applaudissements
m
on va se retrouver là à l'instant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais je tenais merci d'être avec nous
sur les huit avec toute l'équipe
bien sûr
des dos ce soir on revoit des vestes et
on espère tous passé un très bon moment
avec nous et il y à une héroïne ce soir
que 12 ans d'applaudir chez valérie
bénaïm
bravo madame mizen rabot est ce qu'on
peut en voir l'extrait s'il vous plaît
l'extrait de vanille
[Applaudissements]
valérie est vraiment et valérie je vous
jure joue le jeu les genevois billets
pas de là bas donc j'ai lancé comme ça
et on les met la tête je vais vous dire
les grands esprits se rencontrent jeudi
valérie allez on va continuer avec les
jeux télé dans un instant je vous dire
vous allez tester un jeu jean luc
lemoine et isabelle maury bourse que
j'attends ça avec impatience vous allez
devoir chanter
isabelle vous avez guidés par jean luc
je vous expliquerai ce à tout à l'heure
pour le moment on va parler d'une louche
ou est-ce que vous rappelez d'une chaud
et c'était sur canal+ il avait repris un
jeu qui était déjà dans les jeux de 20
heures je sais pas si vous connaissez
les jeux de 20 heures s'il ya des jeunes
qui nous regardent à mon avis doivent
pas connaître
c'est un jeu qui passait sur france 3 et
il faisait les preuves du ni oui ni non
alors le jeu il s'est très bien déroulée
dans les jeux de 20 heures il s'est très
bien déroulé également sur canal+
regardez c'est une grande championne
elle est imbattable
c'est anne elisabeth lemoine qu'on
retrouve bien sûr tous les midis sur
canal+ qu' on aime beaucoup regardé la
inouïe ni nom ni blonde lambert pourquoi
pas il va pas l'appareil ne s'est pas
avoué on aurait pu trouver autre chose
mais 60 secondes
nizar compte sur vous un peu la pression
60 secondes anne-elisabeth on y va
elisabeth lemoine c'est votre vraie
couleur de ses cheveux je suis une vraie
blanc noué
hambourg est fermé
on a eu des maîtresses on lui aurait
écrit lé texte
on aurait dit c'est trop grenon personne
de peshawar une blonde qui dit woods
sonne seconde en disant glande laisse
tomber oh non ça donne je suis blonde
oui je vais vous montrer ça parce que
derrière
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait elle a retenté
l'expérience quelques temps plus tard
est ce qu'elle a réussi non
autre mot interdit basse et blondin ni
oui ni non ni blonde je crois que
l'histoire a rendez-vous maintenant dans
le news show avec anne élisabeth c'est
parti vous vous êtes un peu entraîné
avant de venir ici à jouer au ni oui ni
non
mon fils m'a entraîné m'a dit maman tu
vas pas recommencer à faire la même
bêtise que la dernière fois il a honte
de moi
il a 7 ans qui joue mieux que vous à ce
jeu qui joue mieux que moi et là
concernant vos cheveux parce que c'est
vrai que c'est quand même ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui les avis
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce que on est passé à regarder
penser avant vos cheveux parce que c'est
vrai que c'est quand même ce qui
aujourd'hui comme ça on s'effondre tout
s'effondre alors les nuls ont parodié ce
jeu vous savez comment il convient de
rappeler à oui oui comment mais oui ni
non les couilles
ce sera un ebit ni oui ni ni ni nom ni
beat je crois que c'est ça vous avez dit
les deux mots c'était le ni ni beatnik
oui exact sur la règle du jeu qui est
très très simple il s'agit tout
simplement de le prononcer à aucun
moment ni bits les couilles c'est tout
simplement pareil que le ni oui ni non à
proximité couilles alors attention non
pendant le premier candidat monsieur
manque de pot alors qu'ils manquent de
vous être prêt quand vous vous levez le
matin
quels sont vos premiers gestes avant
tout je me lave la vie le bild et oui
quoi quoi quoi d'autre quoi je me gratte
les coudes des coûts écoute c'est très
très très très bien joué et puis vous
prenez un petit déjeuner tout ça quoi
par exemple du café au lait le matin et
vous trempez vos coups y est croissant
oui oui mais c'est trop tard c'est trop
tard c'est trop tard vous allez quand
même tenu 15 secondes ce qui n'est pas
mal du tout on applaudit bien fort
deuxième candidat
vous êtes de quelle région et bien
j'habite thabeet dit vous l'avez déjà
bits et oui et oui oh c'est dommage
c'est très très bien joué quand même il
y avait un petit piège je dois bien vous
l'avouer mireille vous êtes prête khouya
banon
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et entraînait
lamine ba oui c'est beaucoup plus
difficile devant une caméra mire et vous
êtes tout ému c'est par ici consorts
voilà on va jouer ce soir alors sachez
que je vais y jouer avec gérard louvin
pour commencer gérard louvin vous êtes
forains se joue pas je pense pas alors
c'est pas démarré et je vous dis on va
faire un ami oui ni non
ni deuil ni oui ni non des propos si
vous perdez vous allez devoir vous
chantez vanina en allemand
[Applaudissements]
2 pourquoi la vie
le terme
alors attention c'est parti pour
préparer la bande
gerald on va attention c'est parti pour
une minute dire 'on va vous le voyez
souvent des îles de temps en temps vous
l'aimez bien je laime beaucoup c'est
vrai qu'ils racontent plein de blagues
ou pas il est très drôle
il est drôle mais ont ils parlent
toujours pas très bien pensé ça qui est
drôle il a toujours gardé sur l'action
il a toujours l'accent hollandais aille
bien de gérard nouveau vous allez devoir
francon mot d'allemand valu la en
allemande alors attention c'est parti
gérard louvin on vous écoute
[Musique]
israël
[Applaudissements]
merci animals and ice nunchuk disney
channel chine va tenir ou bring this be
in their eyes ya des gags ben collins
est il me tuer moi jen de l'aiba
[Applaudissements]
mitchell
c'est à vous maintenant messieurs jean
michel mr attention on va jouer à ni oui
ni non
ni tub on va vous rafraîchir à notre
manière puisque valérie bénaïm se
vengera et vous mettra des glaçons au
niveau de votre mental d'accord versera
à tous ses classes au jean michel
seydoux sinon c'est jean luc qui va le
faire aller voilà j'en ai moi si je peux
rendre service
jean-luc attendez attendez qu'ils
perdent non mais je le prépare quand ça
fait du bien dans le bottin pantalon
devant bien sûr devant
attention attention c'est parti mon
salaire unique
jean-michel sa vache ou sans stresser
pas du tout non c'est vrai vous avez
peur pour votre pour l'instant non
[Applaudissements]
attendez on lui met juste un glaçon et
il aura une deuxième chance mais juste à
les deux glaçons de glaçons jean-luc à
les innovations s'il vous plaît
attention si vous perdez là il mettra
tout le saut jean luc et je le connais
il adore ça or à part pour une minute
remettre le chrono à une il promet t
elle jean michel carbou ça vous allez
prendre un petit peu de vacances là
pourront pas qu'il parle bien comprendre
que c'est fini c'est vrai que c'est
terminé les vacances infinie vous et
avec votre vie avec ma fille met en
exergue laitiers ou à l'île d'yeu ça va
il fait beau là bas il fait toujours
beau la base c'est la bande est donc
avec vous êtes vous êtes veniez tout nu
avec votre je ne me suis pas baigner
mais ma fille plusieurs fois c'est vrai
elle elle fait quoi de match commence
d'acheter votre fille non elle apprend à
l'école donc je l'enseigné locale est
parfaite elle nage vraiment bien de
l'espoir comme un jeune âge le troll et
la brasse c'est vrai c'est tout c'était
pas mal et vous et où vous voulez vous
la montrer souvent notre mont à voiture
décapotable à menton dit elle est belle
hein je viens de l'acheter et pas les
fiers de cette voiture a ensuite très
très fier c'est votre poubelle verte et
surtout belges en rêvait depuis
longtemps
non il en a rêvé depuis longtemps bah
oui vous ne les verrez plus longtemps
j'en rêve depuis au moins 30 ans depuis
au moins 30 ans et c'est maintenant vous
l'avez vous êtes heureux je n'ai jamais
été aussi heureux je kiffe vraiment vous
qui fait votre vie un oui
[Applaudissements]
les amis je la soupçonne d'avoir fait ce
jeu fera les glaçons dans le slip
allez jean luc allez-y faites vous
plaisir
il reste dans la ville on aimait et les
voilà bravo aujourd'hui merci jean mais
voilà ça c'est du travail bien fait et
la bassée nos côtés dégueulasse gaulle
est allé dans l'instant à isabelle
morini bosc et jean luc lemoine qui vont
nous faire aussi qui vont tester un jeu
pour le moment on accueille bertrand
charleroi sebha ville a rappelé m
par la france à leur merci d'être là mon
bertrand alors c'est une spéciale jeux
télé aujourd'hui 10 juillet et ben
écoutez c'est très simple je me suis
intéressé aux chroniqueurs de touche pas
qu'ils ont participé à des jeux télé en
touche pas à mes jeux télé je suis en
plein dans le ténéré d'efforts
[Applaudissements]
pilou pilou et on va commencer avec un
cas très épineux le dossier benhaim à
parce que sous ses airs de fille bien
sage et bien branché j'ai pas peur de le
dire c'est une vraie chaudière la
benhaim dans ceux ci
après ce qu'elle a vécu un peu de
respect c'est vrai franchement regardez
c'est souffert elle a souffert
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est une
femme qui a souffert regardez là on est
d'accord pour voir si pato je le regarde
c'est quand même le temps pour lui
d'aller chercher un yaourt dans la
cuisine les images qui vont suivre
peuvent le choquer car si valérie
participent souvent au grand concours
des animateurs de tf1 c'est pas pour
tester sa culture générale non c'est
pour pécho elle n'hésite pas se laisser
tripoter tranquillement rares tout le
paf dont je peux pas vous croire si
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
problème pendant qu'on faisait le slow
il m' a dégrafé mon sac
[Applaudissements]
c
l'ancien
maintenant on fonctionne en binôme avec
celle
à vous lire je commence à comprendre
pourquoi marc emmanuel
après son émission tout son sens mais le
dr stefan mode répond alors allez-y
alexandre debanne est un ami e banon
faisant présenter ensemble matinale sur
chérie fm à l'époque aller et booba
l'adoption des amis est ce que je me
suis déjà perdu faire ça mais non c'est
pas ça c'est qu' il me disait qu'il
pouvait par dessus ma robe avec juste
deux doigts comme sa décrue à décrocher
le des graphes et le soutien-gorge suis
dit je te crois pas et dont la naïveté
de la haine ni quoi que tout le monde a
fait au moins 1000 et laissez-vous
commencé sa très jeune c'est ou tous les
garçons savent faire feu verizon est la
première épreuve du feu ou cdma ont fait
sentir elano la région et laure et
l'aurait la désagrégation qui vous à qui
vous a pris comme ça qui nous a dit hier
j'arrive à le faire en deux n'ont jamais
renoncé avait jamais arrivé jean-luc
vous voulez essayer sur une horreur
allez tu galères mecque et laurent et
l'asean 9 carats soutien-gorge pays d'un
code en fait
non
[Applaudissements]
si vous nous rejoignez sachez qu'il n'y
a pas que ça dans cette émission parce
que nos jeunes autrement et il vient de
mettre des glaçons dans le slip de
jean-michel ensuite et des graphiques la
gorge de l'émission de ma vie à gbagbo
ont fait plaisir à leur était en
épaisseur et nora ou me reste un petit
peu parce que les north a également
participé à des jeux télé mais c'était
en tant qu'animatrice bof ça s'appelait
cachot tâche s était diffusée sur rtl 9
en 2008
alors pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
c'est pas et n'aura l'animatrice qui
présentait ce jeu mais n'aura la
poétesse et son dictionnaire des rimes
en h
si la piste et enora bienvenue dans cash
ou tâche le jeune à l'humour vache et
potache n'est jamais trash
les gagnants repartiront avec leur cash
et les perdants avec leur taille les
hova collinaires belle plume et ya vingt
ans rien est impossible à 20 en étant
massa c'est lorik cyril vous avez
participé à beaucoup de jeu oui oui
notamment qui veut gagner des millions
et comme tous les candidats vous aviez
droit à faire appel à un ami manque de
bol votre copain c'est christophe
carrière donc surtout ne comptait jamais
sur lui pour vous sauver achats le tir
le temps que la question travers ses
cheveux et pour attendre le serveur le
chrono est déjà fini et en plus et ça je
ne tolère pas il est mal poli avec son
patron ne savait pourquoi cher
christophe haut et le dit que l'on
carrache exact les devis et d'ankara et
watan a rien à [__]
si nantes alité au pardon chèche
si la question c'est parti christophe
laquelle de ces femmes célèbres est ici
désigné par son nom de famille dorothée
colette mireille ou arletty je pourrais
m'aider à la question laquelle de ces
femmes est désigné par son nom de
famille dorothée colette mirail ou
arletty c'est à dire que je prenne le
monde fanni c'est sa vie de dix secondes
de riz lait coule est emprisonné mais je
suis largement pas sûr je n'ai pas du
tout aimé ça la prochaine fois si tu
mets 30 secondes cognac mais la question
d'âme et d'amis collègues mais c'est un
collègue cohabitera de ce monde pour
comprendre la question c'est quand même
un monde ce garçon de cholet le gars je
l'appelle pour lui parler
si le gaz la prêche auxquels sont guère
moi cela qui peu de jus et le gars il
faut taper la discut ouais tu sais que
j'ai fait je suis passé j'ai pas vu la
sélection du festival de cannes en fait
à l'homme et le gâteau ce sont deux
choses d'abord un je vous ai donné la
bonne réponse était colette avoir appel
plein
non non non non non non et ensuite je
tiens à dire que c'est absolument pas
truqués ce truc ce jeu qu'est ce qui
vous appelle vous êtes dans la rue
n'importe où machin et ça raccroche
effectivement il ya personne pour vous
dire oh ben merci ceci cela on vous
prévient pas on vous appelle direct
revoir le galeux guèye crois qu'ils vont
faire toutes les missions alloway basse
et je voulais te remercier
je vais tenir à sa fin bon temps comme
vous citez pas eu au téléphone sa place
maintenant aux tauliers du post le vrai
gérard louvin j'espère un cv long comme
un numéro de top chef 40 ans d'amitié
avec die 20 producteurs aujourd'hui le
champion du monde de tulle à vue mais
surtout un [__] d'imitateur perdons
tout de suite 5 secondes avec louvain
qui imite l'indien bon seriez vous un
bon expert alors c'est l'anecdote que
j'ai déjà raconté où j'avais un chef
indien sur le plateau vous savez que les
petits plateau de sacrée soirée ne
devait pas dépasser 7 minutes à peu près
quand on faisait leur interview lui il
arrive et il vit se met à bénir le
plateau ça a duré huit minutes et il
faisait au bio est en mono à chier et
moi j'étais à la région direct gelé il
tu veux pas l'arrêter c'est impossible
nico comme déjà foucault couple un
couple eux mêmes et la simazine
jean-pierre allait tuer alors tout le
monde était debout ge est ce qu'il avait
demandé à tout le monde de se mettre
debout la france entière parce que là on
m'a dit moi dans marianne il faut
absolument que tu coupes louvain
et ça a bien marché c'est on le sait
marché arrive son dada c'est sa grande
passion mais vous c'est la chanson
grande passion vous avez été un candidat
exceptionnel dans n'oubliez pas les
paroles mais nagui aurait peut-être dû
rebaptisé l'émission n'oubliez pas de
chanter juste
[Musique]
là
la boulangerie
de là
[Musique]
il
et
très
d'autant que
trois cents
vannes avant qu'olic le soir dans sa
boutique à ce jeune artiste ambitieux il
vous est très fort mais il ya plus fort
que vous seriez l'ia jean luc lemoine
ayasse elle pequenito rossignol du paf
vous ne savez pas quoi offrir pour un
anniversaire j'ai ce qu'il vous faut
la copine de moine une heure de pur
délire avec sa reprise de nuit de folie
en duo avec aimants johnny
[Musique]
voire de fermer
et en bonus track sur la compil moins
haut les mains d'ottawa avec les chinois
sur la fin
[Musique]
je ne suis
on
[Musique]
à
donné pour
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup
vous vous sentez bien vous isabelle
morini bosc
généralement je chante juste pour peu
que je connaisse le chanceur vous
connaissez ottawan 1 vous connaissez ça
ou pas cette chanson là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en quarts
les oulémas
[Applaudissements]
jean-luc vous avez fait équipe avec eve
angeli dans n'oubliez pas les paroles
et bien tout de suite vous allez faire
équipe avec isabelle morini bosc
je vais vous dire de quoi il s'agit
regardez c'est une émission qui passe
qui s'appelle killer karaoké qui fait un
carton
regardez ce qu'ils ont fait on va faire
la même chose tout de suite avec
isabelle morini bosc et jean luc lemoine
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous l'avez dit isabelle va tenter de
chanter au léman dowtown alors que jean
lui qui contrôle ces braves à tout faire
pour l'en empêcher alors jean-luc vous
démarrez de cette table vous découvrirez
la cloche ici ensuite vous irez devant à
gauche avec cette cloche là et vous
finirez par celle ci jean-luc isabelle
on vous entend et il n'arrêtait jamais
je dis bien jamais de chanter l'accord
isabelle win un faire un gros bisou mais
j'en ai eu la chance que j'ai perdu mes
seins parce qu on y entrait pas tous
allez c'est parti
les marocains d'alençon
[Applaudissements]
donnez moi ton cas
m
ou pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous ai craché l'autre
[Applaudissements]
on les mains on les bat
m
[Applaudissements]
bravo monsieur briatore pourrait
retomber à votre place et il ya une
odeur la sorgue s'aimer horrible
horrible à ces eaux là
au fait tu attends attends d injuste il
ya quelqu'un qui vous salue c'est la
pieuvre
ah oui là bas
ce jour là d'un même lot de la vienne
oui bah c'est comme ça allait au 4e tour
et en achetant sur les mythes vous
restez avec nous il y aura logique roady
crois pas enlever encore d'autres
extraits bien sûr on va récupérer jean
luc lemoine et isabelle jarry vivace à
tout
[Musique]
la dernière partie de tous par des gens
allaient attaquer tout cas des cobayes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le monde celle allant du fayot à la
rocade est savamment le mcg a compris à
lecture l'a vu à la télé ce soir
s'annonce âpre assassine spéciale jeux
télé bien sûr ça fait plaisir à beaucoup
de monde
enfin un plateau à votre envergure ses
rimes pas là pour ça on est pas logique
à on peut prendre le scooter de quoi
aller bosser les sauces charger il
m'intéressait bien sûr mois aux
candidats des jeux télé c'est ça qui
m'intéresse au sort va commencer par m
au t1 us motus et je voulais vous
présenter gabriel c'est sans doute le
plus jeune candidat de l'histoire de
motus et le gars il est à fond on sent
qu'il a fait là harvard motus institute
il vit que pour ça parce qu'ils te
balance les mots en un quart de seconde
on n'a jamais vu ça une 45 vaudoise v a
eu des oui et ce voyage j'ai eu à
hideuse et le vigilant bjr l amt
relayeur est re elle a écrit que m by
romain larue la mayenne au droit b a eu
des royaumes blindage b allende a relevé
qu'aucun histoire et un jour à motus
ils ont pas donné une bonne réponse je
vous jure que c'est vrai c'est pas la
bride et et deux gars qu'on va voir
maintenant ce que vous allez voir qu'ils
sont pas loin de ça passe il faut pas
croire que tous les candidats sont comme
ce jeune homme dans motus tous à fond il
ya aussi des gens comme nous qui s'en
foutent parce qu'on a trouvé les deux
gars peut-être les potes de cyril les
plus beaux vais de toute l'histoire de
motus à mon avis il est gavé jamais vu
motus de leur vie avant où il avait pris
français lv3 au lycée regardez on les a
comparés à des candidates habituel c'est
vraiment pas le même niveau militaire
ami ali tahiri
critérium c'est hérité de herri
traducteur tr a débuté hier
compliments c'est owen pmi libération la
libye mais rate et yoann chipoter
chipolatas imprimerie il n'ya rien
meirieu son dos misé s au bo est miné ce
faire il n'y était pas soudas les savait
quoi allez on le lance on s'en fout quoi
mais on verra bien où ça nous mène motus
est pas un jeu simple à eux et comme
dans tous les jeux il ya chaque jour un
grand gagnant c'est le principe de jeu
est parfois dans l'euphorie de la
victoire on peut dire des choses très
curieuse même franchement quand même pas
au point de ce qu'on va voir puisque
j'ai jamais vu deux potes gagner un truc
ils gagnent ensemble motus et dire ça je
pense qu'ils ont des choses inachevé
entre ses deux potes faut qu'ils parlent
après goût luge et ruelles us jolie ge
au lmr si c'est ça je te bénis béninois
bénir
[Applaudissements]
bon juste pour finir sur mottu je
voudrais donner un conseil aux
dirigeants de france 2 je m'adresse
directement aux raccourcis ceylan chouïa
le générique de fin
parce qu'il est interminable et du coup
thierry beccaro sait plus trop quoi
faire pour meubler parce qu'il est quand
même à l'image et du coup bas tout ce
qui fait il fait ce qu'il peut mais il
est très seul quoi à la prochaine fois
j'espère que vous serez des nôtres
bonne journée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai aussi je surveillais une famille en
gold renoncer c'est la version
américaine d'une famille en or ce serait
bien sûr il ya aussi là bas aux états
unis parce que je sais pas où est ce
qu'ils cassent leurs familles pour faire
une famille en or aux états unis mais vu
les réponses il faut qu'ils attendent un
peu avant de se lancer dans questions
pour un champion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dassault stasi quand même mais c'est la
pression s quand on a la pression dans
les jeux où on dit parfois des bêtises
vous le verrez enfin chronique on vous
reconnaîtrez quelqu'un et comment parler
de jeu sans parler du jeu le plus ancien
de la télévision française cela dit si
bien sûr way qui est à ma droite c'est
quelqu'un d'ici mai jour de ce que c'est
on va y revenir
non pas ça abonde géographie géographie
fall à ce niveau là c'est plus de la
géographie jeu qui touchent pas ton
satya ta vie je te montre que vous en
ferez ce que vous voulez et comment
parler de jeu sans parler du jeu le plus
ancien de la télévision française qu'est
ce que c'est mais je dois avouer noir
est toujours là elle est maintenant
c'est très moche que le swahili pour la
guerre aux chômeurs s'en aller et les
candidats qui vont là bas aux chiffres
et aux lettres
bien sûr sont toujours bien reçus par
laurent romejko sauf une monique on sait
par la pauvre monique elle tombe sur un
tirage un peu olé olé sa rivale y est
pour rien et se prend une grosse vanne
d'ariane alors qu'elle avait rien
demandé du toulouse
monique j'ai joué six milliards 7
ouais alors en 6 monique enlevés voilà
vous marquerez six mois qu avez-vous vu
en s'accumuler et ensuite aisance et une
émission dans laquelle on peut dire ce
mot ah oui tout à fait ah ouais ouais ça
fait bien vous arrivez jouer elle besoin
l'arrêt à côté ne serait pas traité ça
c'était pas été dans des gymnases
c'est rare que quelqu'un reviennent chez
lui comment ça s'est passé dans une
mosquée vraiment c'est la seule à qui
c'est arrivé confie guila autre jeu qui
cartonne en ce moment aux appareils en
début d'émission c'est tout le monde
veut prendre sa place avec nagui chaque
midi sur france 2 et ils ont une autre
catégorie de candidats c'est le candidat
hyper connus qu'ils glissent là
incognito
[Musique]
ça va bien ça va
apparemment ce faire ce passionné par
les états unis olivier à quel point il
est souvent est-ce que vous avez reconnu
olivier pour toi il est très très connus
rappelé monde olivier bonjour je suis
obligé de penser que cet impact est trop
petit et que ça ne vaut pas le coup de
son député
j'adore parce que dans le puits c'est
olivier de carné ascquois ont déjà 90
ans on dirait qu'on leur a montré
comment les bras et on ne sait pas dans
les jeux télé en finir là dessus des
candidats sont pas mal stressé
du coup parfois une sorte de bonnes
bourde on se quitte avec elle a laissé
moral et ça va merci d'un but commun
alors on fait le dernier roger parent
après ça on se quitte avec un petit pot
pourri très pourri de réponse improbable
dans les jeux télé en france avait
trompé non tir home sales aux poissons
truies femmes morue
on peut vous paraître improbable mais la
manne de la mauvaise réponse à jean n'ai
eu d'après je sais pas s'ils voulaient
la voir je fais toujours
il fait ce jour ce sera
nos mots de passe non mais oui mais
j'vous c'est plus le mot et c'est au
dessus
un dessus des buts écoutez si ici
vraiment est ce que ça veut faire passer
une bonne soirée
franchement oui alors c'est quoi le
plaisir vous le faites mais sans moi je
sors pendant la séquence efforts pernaut
emballage ce soir à mende ensuite on va
le faire et vous ça reste entre nous en
plateau vous dites pas que vous l'avez
vu à ce que l'aviez pas loin je mens tu
la mets va être comme si de rien n'était
certains biens publics et tous et vous
aussi
le futur normal il était stressé bon bah
quand on est stressé voilà et qu'on
allait sécher question de géographie en
troisième puisque la palme de la
mauvaise réponse revient donc à cette
personne qui vient de quitter le club
le studio dans mot de passe regarder
france
bangkok bangkok
oui bah bien sûr bangkok japon venir l'a
pas vu comment ça va camille commence
mal sa chronique standard mais moi j'ai
terminé allez allez je file aux partis
anti pas en vacances
ouais moi je vais partir quelques jours
est où ça un ouh ça dans ton cul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas si vous passez un bon moment
chez vous mais où on va voir ça on va
voir ça c'est le gall a dit ça tombait
sous le sens avait alors attendu dans un
instant il y aura un bowling humain
et oui je vous le dis on va essayer de
faire le bowling humain avec l'équipe
ici puisqu'on va parler d'un jeu
japonais et deux japonais qui font un
carton
mais pour le moment on va passer aux j'y
crois j'y crois pas si vous nous
rejoignez un sur des beats et une grande
soirée autour des jeux télé ils testent
des jeux on regarde bien sûr plein de
l'image de jeu et j'espère que vous vous
régaler avec nous sur des vitres tout de
suite j'y crois j'y crois pas c'est
parti alors on a trouvé des images très
très étonnant de jeu télé vous me dîtes
si vous y croyez ou pas on y va un
candidat qui se réincarne en annie cordy
dans une émission de nagui
j'y crois j'y crois pas enora vous y
croyez pour vous que vous le sentez
comment vous l'avez vu vous connais en
chine aura vous y croyez tout le monde y
croit et signant le seul maire qui n'y
croient pas du barça me sens pouvait
demander manque un animal
[Rires]
enfin que le monsieur a dit un candidat
ait compris un animal qui seront soit en
hélico renonce à dalida qui suppose en
bas du corps des mines renault chantal
goya charlotte julian rouas dit qu'en
dit annie cordy si chaud
à
[Musique]
tout seul chocolat ce collectif il est
petit qui lit les motards bat méchant
je suis fou de solutions je suis tous
nos livres voilà voilà face aux plus
grands fans
est ce qu'il peut nous contacter est ce
qui peut nous contacter sur le facebook
de l'émission ou sur twitter un vraiment
et nous donner ses coordonnées
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on fasse un duo
en somme sur annie cordy et s'il le faut
jamais draps ni corps ni dans les
missions que j'aime beaucoup aussi parce
qu'il est exceptionnel
est ce qu'on a vu un candidat très
maladroit qui avale la boule noire dans
motus et se fait évacuer enjeux du jeu
en urgence non la panne on n'a pas pu
assurer que cécile croyais pas au podium
je ne croyais pas du tout à nos tifosi
croiser un candidat dans un jeu qui
imite parfaitement le bruit de la
tronçonneuse je crois que j'y crois
vous imitez d'aider des bruits font par
exemple vous savez faire des bruits
c'est quoi ça c'est les bruins et
monfils étant petit mais ça va pas nous
examinons bonjour monsieur le maire il
est des plus réussis et vous ça vous
savez faire un truc qu'on essaie de
retrouver à l'arrosage automatique avait
fait un bruit vallée village qu'est ce
que je fais c'est de trouver d'accord
d'accord
la friteuse ses cheveux l'aspirateur
danger et jovial
je viens comprend elle se fait c'est
possible avec un aspirateur
c'est pour ça qu'elle est comme ça jean
luc lemoine ses fautes qui fait très
bien le pistolet de la série bon la
mitraillette
[Applaudissements]
gardner je trouvais pas cela comme à
l'école répond très triste non je viens
c'est la tronçonneuse savez quoi
quand je lui ai demandé je savais que ça
allait être très triste
regardez ce garçon qui fait vraiment
bien la tronçonneuse regarder bonsoir je
m'appelle damiani gauche et 29 ans
j'habite à aigre ville je suis mis
theater d'objets et quel objet pouvez
vous imiter pour nous damien poids
plusieurs par exemple la tronçonneuse
[Applaudissements]
bravo la mobylette
c'est très très impressionnant et vont
pouvoir commencer
rouge ou battiston un sylvain mirouf joe
roth s'est pas vus cayenne parle je mets
des jupes culottes et je dois pas 100
parfait bien jouer vous annoncez de deux
lurons d'entrée jean francs sur une
réaction je sus manéo et je saute sur
olivier minne au lit viet-minh c'est la
carte mystère
vas-y vase a bien joué vous gardez votre
joker vous avez dit couillon damien vis
ma vie ou sans du fion je [__] sur un
sumo et j'embrasse sophia loren sur le
cul vous avancé de 3 mouflons et vous
tombez en cases au théâtre ce soir
damien zizanie ou kenavo jura des mines
saucisses et kamoulox ou bravo jean
françois vous êtes notre finalistes
évidemment on se retrouve demain pour un
autre camou locks et un petit mot avant
de se quitter messieurs pipe caisse
bonsoir et à demain toute la circulation
donc si vous avez envie que le cas
bouloc reviennent vers un jour on
avisera kad et olivier nous ils nous le
ferons j'espère pour nous ils sont
excellents et derrière c'était manu
c'est un garçon qui travaille avec nous
à comédie qui était pas du tout là
dedans fait il s'occupait de la lumière
tout ça et il s'est retrouvé dans le
cadre ou locks manu que j'embrasse en
tout cas si nous regarde est ce que vous
croyez qu'un japonais a pu casser des
noix avec ses fesses dans vous y croyez
elle a certes fait l'unanimité on dirait
qu'ils habitent ces zones
alors ça c'était un japonais qui le fait
mais il ya aussi et laura vous êtes fan
de rien fanon mais il ya un français
c'est ça qui détient le record du monde
je crois et qui c'est très drôle ce qui
pousse des petits cris à chaque fois
qu'un chinois basse assez douloureux je
les fais avec des pastèques c'est tout
le rôle regard des ténors mercier
animera bonera jour sur le plateau on
vous faire plaisir
alors vous avez envie de voir un jeu
japonais et c'est vrai que dans les jeux
c'est les plus forts c'est fou gérard
comment se fait-il qu'il soit aussi
foulé japonais pour inventer des trucs
comme ça ils n'ont pas de limites c'est
ça il nous propose des choses des fois
mais c'est ce sont des ja leader des foo
excusez moi parce que les japonais qui
l'on regarde mais ils n'ont aucune
limite à ccq parce que même ça comment
on peut avoir idée une seconde de dire
on va faire un championnat de la version
que c'est bien jacques delattre gobelet
sur le front oui il ya certains jeux qui
en france passerait pour de
l'humiliation ça passe très bien chasser
ça c'est ça oui et dans vidéo gag il
avait dû intervenir sur les images qui
venait du japon parce que les parents
provoqué des accidents avec leurs
enfants mais il mettait une table une
tabouret une chaise et l'enfant aussi au
sommet ah ouais but c'était qui se casse
la figure donc l'ex beau jurer le csa
français vit jamais plus d'image
japonaise dans la vidéo gag
ben c'est faux vous êtes très au courant
de ce qui se passait dans vidéo gag
c'est votre émission préférée une
histoire mais je j'adore merci
heureusement que vous êtes là parce que
j'avais touche pas les jeux télé merci
mais vous savez tout à l'heure que
justement dans la roue de la fortune
quand on voyait des saintes victoria
machin est bien dans la version
française on a fait baisser le niveau de
la roue pour que quand elle se penche
on voit bien plus ses ceintures dans la
version américaine fort ça aurait avoué
que la bravo isabelle molosse de
réversion vraiment bien sûr
il avait l'air libre est ce que vous
connaissez je hais poitrine à aller tout
de suite regardé ce qu'ils font au japon
m
tél
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et voilà ce que pour les japonais et de
l'agent du seul maire te feras et
christophe carrière vous essayez de
faire le bowling humain
jean michel meyer vous allez vous
élancer au 1er jean michel c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon je suis à fond
allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
jean michel lair qui a fait tomber comme
l équipe on va voir s'il nous fait lui
le christophe carrière c'est parti un
strike de christophe carrière qui va
être opposé aux moines shaolin le
champion des champions
sachez le c'est un mélange du rebelle du
père fouras et également de de maître
miyagi dans karate kid
regardez qu'il est là cette fois pas
fait attention
[Applaudissements]
hortefeux
je tenais
remercier toute l'équipe d'avoir est
avec toi merci à tous d'avoir été là et
l'oubli
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]